[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Google Cloud enables
you to migrate virtual machine
instances, images, or disks
from on premise environments
or other Cloud providers
to Compute Engine.
There are several ways
you can migrate workloads
to Compute Engine, including
migrate for Compute Engine,
importing virtual appliances,
or importing virtual disks.
In this video, we
will focus on how
to import virtual appliances
and virtual disks.
Migrating virtual
appliances and virtual disks
is best suited for
small number of VMs.
If you want to migrate
a large number of VMs,
check out Migrate
for Compute Engine.
The first scenario will cover
importing virtual appliances,
followed with virtual disks.
Virtual appliance
is a package that
contains hardware
configuration and disk
images for a VM instance.
Before you start
a migration, you
should always check if the OS
is supported for migration,
check if the OS is
compatible for migration
by running the
precheck tool, choose
if you will use your
own license keys
or if you will use Google
Cloud's pay as you go model,
set up a storage bucket,
grant IAM permissions
for the import operation.
After we complete the
migration prerequisites,
we will do one of
the following--
either export the VMs
into OVA or OVF format
and upload them to a
GCS bucket, or export
the virtual disks,
which are in VMDK
or VHD format to a GCS bucket.
Check out this documentation for
more information on uploading
files to a GCS bucket.
For this example,
we have already
uploaded an OVF package and
one good disk to a bucket.
Next, we import the OVF
files into a Compute Engine.
We can import machine images
through a gcloud command
or a Compute Engine API.
We have two options
when importing.
We can either create
an instance directly
while importing the OVF, or
import it as a machine image,
then create a new
instance from that image.
The command on the screen
imports the virtual appliance
directly into an instance.
The source URI here is the
path to the OVF directory.
There you go.
We have successfully
imported an instance
from a virtual appliance.
The command shown here
creates a machine image
from this virtual appliances,
and these machine images
can be used to create
instances later on.
There are many flags
available for custom settings,
such as byol to specify
bring your own license model,
project to specify the project
you want to import this image,
zone to specify the zone in
which image to be imported,
guest OS features to enable
one or more supported features.
You can explore more of these
flags in the documentation.
There you go.
We have successfully
imported the machine image
from the virtual appliance.
Next we will cover how
to import virtual disks.
Virtual disk is a file used by
virtual machines that emulate
an actual disk storage device.
Migration prerequisites
remains the same
for importing virtual disks.
We can import
virtual disks using
Google Cloud console, Google
Cloud CLI, and Compute Engine
API.
In Google Cloud console,
go to Create an Image page.
Specify a name of the
image and a source.
Select virtual disk, browse
the virtual disk file,
specify the
operating system that
is available in
the imported disk,
then click Create
to import the image.
Congratulations.
We have successfully created
an image from the virtual disk.
Check out the documentation to
learn more about Compute Engine
migration parts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]